ON. A GOOD AFTERNOON. OUR WHERE
AYE AYE KNOWS WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM IS TIME SO WE'RE GOING
TO START THE AT EDUCATION
HEARING AS A SUBCOMMITTEE OF
BEFORE YOU START I WANNA KNOW
THE PRESENCE OF OUR NEWEST
MEMBER. I WAS MAKING DOLLY
WELCOME EDUCATION COMMITTEE
RECORD TO WORKING. WITH YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION ON THIS
COMMITTEE- AND- SO THERE IS.
JUST A QUICK NOTE HERE- WE DID
HAVE A COUPLE MEMBERS THAT. HAD
MADE PLANS TO START FIRST BUT
THEY'RE NOT HERE SO WE'RE
PROBABLY GONNA HAVE TO GO WITH
ANOTHER MEMBER- BUT JUST SO YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU DO COME FORWARD
IT'S TWO WITNESSES. FOR EACH
SIDE. TWO MINUTES EACH AND THAT
IS LIMITED THAT WHAT OTHERS MAY
DO. YOU WISH TO WEIGH IN ON THE
BILL AS STATE THEIR NAME.
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL NAME
AFFILIATION IMPOSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY AFTER MICROPHONE
AFTERWARDS. SO WITH THAT SEEING
THAT WE DO NOT HAVE OUR FIRST-
DESIGNATED- OTHERS HERE WHEN WE
GO AHEAD WITH FRIEDMAN AND
START WITH AB- TO SEVENTY SIX.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AND NUMBER
TWO. THREE WE ARE IN FILE ITEM
THREE THEM CORRECTED FILE ITEM
THREE MISREADING YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY. REMEMBER MY
STAFF AND YOU CAN. EXACTLY. THE
FOR THE GREENHOUSES AB TWO
SEVENTY SIX THE WHOLE THING
RIGHT. FIVE REQUIRE THREE.
THAT'S ABOUT IT. NINETY FOUR
MILLION CHILDREN IN A SINGLE.
75% OF CHILDREN GO WITH IT IS
WORKING IN THEIR HOME ONE IN
FIVE PARENTS DID NOT KNOW THAT
THEIR CHILD AND HANDLE THEIR
BECAUSE WITHOUT THE REVISION.
75% OR SO AS A RESULT BY
CHILDREN HAVING ACCESS TO. I
DON'T SUPPORT YOUR PRICE DOWN.
THERE WERE FORTY QUESTION
SHOOTINGS AND FORTY SIX WEEKS
LAST YEAR FOR WHICH WERE HELD
FOR HIM I JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO.
THERE WAS A SUICIDE IN MY
DISTRICT. AT ALL TO FIND HIS
PARENTS UNLOCKED GUN THANK YOU
I THOUGHT I SOUNDED QUIET. I
DON'T NEED TO START OVER DO I.
OKAY NO YOU'RE DOING GREAT
THANK YOU CALIFORNIA HAS SOME
OF THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE SAFE
FIREARM STORAGE LAWS IN THE
COUNTRY INCLUDING REQUIRING ALL
FIREARMS SOLD IN CALIFORNIA BE.
ACCOMPANIED BY A DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO APPROVED FIREARM
SAFETY DEVICE. EVEN WITH OUR
CHILD ACCESS PREVENTION AND
COMPREHENSIVE SAGE STORAGE LAWS
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE REGULAR
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS ACROSS OUR
STATE CHILDREN CONTINUE TO FIND
UNLOCKED. GUNS IN THEIR HOMES A
NOTIFICATION SENT HOME TO
PARENTS AS THIS BILL WOULD-
PROMOTE INSURES THAT FAMILIES
KNOW WHEN WHERE AND HOW FAR OR
NEEDS TO BE SAFELY STORED. THIS
NOTICE THIS CERTIFICATION IS A
ROCK A RECOMMENDATION FROM
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN LA CITY
ATTORNEY MIKE FUEHRER AND IS
BEGINNING. IT IS THE ADVOCATES
WILL TELL YOU REACH OUT TO
WHATEVER OVER TWO THOUSAND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE IS NOT FEASIBLE AND IT'S
REASONABLE THE PARENTS WOULD
ASSUME THAT THE SAME
NOTIFICATIONS BEEN SENT HOME.
TO PARENTS OF CHILDREN THEY
MIGHT BE SENDING THEIR KIDS TO
PLAY WITH REGARDLESS OF WHAT
SCHOOL DISTRICT THEIR CHILD
MIGHT BE AN- TING TOOLS TO
NAVIGATE. OR USE A FIREARM
STORAGE LAWS IN ORDER TO KEEP
THEIR OWN CHILDREN SAFE. AB TWO
SEVENTY SIX OF FACILITATES
EDUCATION BY REQUIRING. THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. IN
CONSULTATION WITH APARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. TO PRODUCE A
STANDARDIZED NOTIFICATION. THAT
WILL ANNUALLY BE SENT HOME FROM
HARTFORD TO PERRANCE. SAVE
STORAGE SAVES LIVES LET'S MAKE
SURE THAT PARENTS HAVE ALL THE
TOOLS THAT THEY NEED TO KEEP.
OURTHEIR KIDS SAFE. WITH ME TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT IS DONALD BILL
FINKELSTEIN OF THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY CHAPTER. A BRADY YOU
CALIFORNIA UNITED AGAINST GUN
VIOLENCE. AND A BOARD MEMBER OF
WITH AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. JUST ONE MOMENT
LOOKING LOOKED ME ESTABLISH A
CORE. SECURE PLEASE STEPS WERE.
O'DONNELL HERE BUT ON HERE
KILEY KILEY HERE. DELHI DELHI
HERE KALRA MCCARTY SMITH SMITH
HERE WEBER WEBER HERE. OKAY SO
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO THIS
MEETING WILL BE CALLED TO ORDER
RIGHT NOW SO WITH THAT YOU'RE
WITNESSES MAY PERCEIVE. HEALTHY
GUEST OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS DONNA FINKELSTEIN AND
I'M A TWENTY YEAR MAN OF THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY CHAPTER OF-
BRADY UNITED AGAINST GUN
VIOLENCE AND A BOARD MEMBER OF
WOMEN AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE. WHO
WE PARTNER WITH. PROFESSIONALLY
THOUGH FOR THE PAST THIRTY
YEARS I WORK AS A HIGH SCHOOL
COUNSELOR WITH LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. MOST
IMPORTANTLY I AM A MOTHER OF
TWO DAUGHTERS AND A GRANDMOTHER
TWO THREE BEAUTIFUL
GRANDCHILDREN. WITH ONE ON THE
WAY MY YOUNGEST DAUGHTER MINDY
AT AGE SIXTEEN. SURVIVOR BEING
SHOT IN A HATE CRIME IT WAS
AUGUST OF NINETEEN NINETY NINE
WHEN A GUNMAN STORMED THE NORTH
VALLEY JEWISH COMMUNITY CENTER
IN GRANADA HILLS CALIFORNIA. TO
KILL JEWS. MY HUSBAND AND I
HAVE LIVED EVERY PARENT'S
NIGHTMARE. I AM HERE TO ASK YOU
TO SUPPORT AB TWO SEVENTY SIX
TO BOLSTER CALIFORNIA'S SAFE
STORAGE LAWS CALIFORNIA HAS
STRONG CHILD ACCESS PREVENTION
LAWS BUT MANY PARENTS DO NOT
KNOW ABOUT THIS LAW. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH WOMEN AGAINST
GUN VIOLENCE AND BRADY
CALIFORNIA LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT PASSED A
RESOLUTION IN JUNE OF NINETEEN
LAST YEAR TO DO JUST THAT AND
HAS ALREADY BEGUN THE
DISTRIBUTION PROCESS. SCHOOL
SAFETY IS OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE TO ALL PARENTS
SCHOOL STAFF AND THE
COMMUNITIES AT LARGE. LAST YEAR
OVER FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE WERE
KILLED DUE TO GUN VIOLENCE
INCLUDING AT LEAST SEVENTY SIX
INCIDENCES OF GUNFIRE ON OUR
NATION'S SCHOOL GROUNDS
RESULTING IN ELEVEN DEATHS
INCLUDING THREE SUICIDES AND
FORTY SIX INJURIES. THE
MAJORITY OF SCHOOL SHOOTINGS
WERE COMMITTED BY MINORS AND
WHERE THERE WAS A KNOCK WHERE
THERE WAS KNOWLEDGE OF THE GUNS
ORIGIN. 80% OF THE SHE SHE'S
THE GUN HERE SHE OBTAINED FROM
THEIR HOME OR FROM THE HOME OF
A RELATIVE. SENDING HOME SAFE
STORAGE INFORMATION TO PARENTS
IS NOT A REACTIVE MEASURE. AT
SCHOOL WE HOLD ACTIVE SHOOTER
DRILLS AND HAVE EXPERIENCE
LOCKDOWNS IN FACT I JUST GOT A
CALL THIS MORNING THAT THE HIGH
SCHOOL I WORKING WITH UNDER
LOCKDOWN. WE ALSO DO CRISIS
TRAINING FOR FACULTY. PARENTS
NEED TO BE INFORMED AND BE
RESPONSIBLE AS WELL. THIS IS A
PREVENTATIVE MEASURE MUCH LIKE
OTHER PREVENTIVE MEASURES WE
TAKE TO KEEP OUR CHILDREN SAFE
SEAT BELTS AGE RESTRICTIONS ON
CIGARETTE PURCHASES DRIVING AND
TEXTING LOST. WE HAVE BRADY
CALIFORNIA RECOMMENDS THAT THE
SAFE GOING STORAGE INFORMATION
ON CALIFORNIA'S LAWS WHICH IS
THE CAP BE SENT HOME TO ALL
STUDENTS WHO ATTEND PUBLIC AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS PREVENTING
CHILD ACCESS TO FIRE ARMS NOT
ONLY REDUCES THE RISK OF
UNINTENTIONAL AND SUICIDAL
SHOOTINGS IN THE HOME BUT ALSO
PRODUCES THE RISK OF SHOOTING.
AT SCHOOL PLEASE SUMMERS. THIS
INFORMATION WILL BE A SMALL
STEP TOWARD PREVENTING GUN
VIOLENCE IN KEEPING OUR
CHILDREN SAFE WE ARE COUNTING
ON YOU SO FAR MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE PASSES
RESOLUTION INCLUDING LAUSD
CULVER CITY MANHATTAN BEACH
PENDING SANTA MONICA LAST
VIRGINIS THANK YOU. YOUR NEXT
WITNESS. FROM THE SEVENTY THE
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. THAT'S
RIGHT- MY NAME IS PICKING THE
CROWN I LIVE IN LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA. I AM THE LONG BEACH
CHAPTER PRESIDENT AND THE PAST
PRESIDENT- FOR THE STATEWIDE
CALIFORNIA PRETTY CHAPTERS- IN
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES MY
BROTHER- ROBERT KELLY WAS SHOT
AND KILLED IN A ROBBERY AS HE
WAS WALKING TO HIS CAR FROM THE
STORE. AND IT IT JUST CHANGED
EVERYTHING FOR OUR FAMILY IT
THINGS WHICH- YOU RECOVER BUT
YOU REALLY DON'T REALLY EVER
EVER. FULLY RECOVER YOU NEVER
FULLY REAL REALLY GET OVER IT
YOU JUST LEARN TO LIVE WITH IT.
SO I'M HERE TODAY TO REPRESENT
THE MANY MANY SOUTH THE
FAMILIES THAT HAVE BEEN FORCED
TO LIVE. WITH THE TERRIBLE
CONSEQUENCES. OF THE GUN
VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC IN THIS
COUNTRY. BRADY IS SPONSORING
EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY SIX BECAUSE
THE SAFE STORAGE OF FIREARMS
HAS BEEN A KEY PART OF OUR WORK
FOR MANY DECADES. AND IT'S ONLY
RIVER. THAT PARENTS TO OWN
FIREARMS NO THE
RESPONSIBILITIES. THAT IS WHY
THE CALIFORNIA BRADY CHAPTERS
ARE ASKING THIS COMMITTEE TO
PLEASE PASS EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU OTHERS
SUPPORT MAY COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE STATE THEIR NAME OF.
AN AFFILIATION A POSITION ON
THE ONLY PLACE AMANDA WILCOX ON
BEHALF OF THE NEVADA PLASTER
CHAPTER OF BRADY CALIFORNIA
UNITED AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JIM WHEN
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION TO
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. SHE GOT
HAMEL TEN ORGANIZING MANAGER
FOR BRADY NATIONAL UNITED
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT.
VIDEO BORN REPRESENTING
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION IN SUPPORT.
SYLVIA SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES CITY ATTORNEY MIKE
FEUER AND VERY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SEE NO
OTHERS TO SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. I SEE
NO. ALL JUST MAKE A QUICK
COMMENT I MISREAD THANK YOU FOR
THE BILL ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE IS A GOOD
THING ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
EDUCATE ANCESTOR THEIR ROLE. IN
PREVENTING GUN VIOLENCE WHICH I
KNOW IS THE GOAL OF THIS BILL I
THINK IT'S A GOOD THING- I
THINK WE ALL KNOW MANY
TRAGEDIES. WE'VE THEY'VE BEEN
WITH US HERE TODAY. THAT
FAMILIES HAVE HAVE HAVE
SUFFERED BECAUSE OF GUN
VIOLENCE SO AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR. FOR THIS PIECE IN THE
EFFORT TO END GUN VIOLENCE. I
WITH THAT I'M GONNA SEE IF ANY
OF THE OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WISH TO SPEAK. MR MET THE SMITH.
I AM I THINK. THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES TODAY FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD- AS YOU KNOW
MY COLLEAGUE FROM GLENDALE
SAGAS HIGH SCHOOL WAS THE MOST
RECENT SHOOTING THAT TOUCH MY
DISTRICT. NOVEMBER FOURTEENTH.
AND WHAT IT HAS BEEN CLEAR THE
THAT THE FINAL INVESTIGATION IS
NOT BEEN. COMPLETED AS THAT THE
YOUNG MAN WHO WAS BOTH I
BELIEVE THAT THE PERPETRATOR
BUT ALSO A VICTIM. HAD GREATER
ACCESS TO A WEAPON THAT HE HAD
TO MENTAL HEALTH HELP AND
SUPPORT AND SO I THINK THIS
MEASURE GOES. ONE SMALL PART
THE WAY TO THE REST OF THE WORK
THAT WE DO NEED TO CONTINUE TO
DO BUT- I PLAN TO SUPPORT TODAY
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORTS ON THIS. THANK YOU MISS
WITH THE OTHERS WISH TO SPEAK
I'M A STAR. HI SO I'M CURIOUS
IF THE AUTHOR WOULD CONSIDER
INCLUDING AN EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENT FOR PUPILS ALONG WITH
PARENTS FOR EDUCATION. I THINK
IT WOULD BE DIFFICULT TO
DEVELOP ONE STANDARD-
EDUCATIONAL DOCUMENT FOR ALL
GRADE LEVELS AND BECAUSE THIS
IS MEANT TO GO TO ALL PARENTS
FROM KINDERGARTEN ALL THE WAY
UP TO HIGH SCHOOL- I THINK THAT
THAT WOULD BE DIFFICULT IN THIS
CONTEXT I THINK THAT THIS YES
YOU HAVE DEVELOPED SOMETHING
STUDENTS IS A VERY. GOOD ONE-
GETTING THAT STUDENTS COULD
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
NECESSARILY IN A CHILD'S
ANOTHER CHILD MAY SHOW UP WITH
THAT- WEAPON WHEN THEY FIND ONE
ON THE PLAYGROUND- BUT I THINK
THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE HAVE TO
BE A LONGER CONVERSATION
BECAUSE GOING TO FOR FREE. FOR
H. LEVELS BUT I APPRECIATE THE
SUGGESTION. THANK THE BILL.
THANK THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED WITH THAT- SEE NO
FURTHER COMES FROM ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU MAY CLOSE
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT I DO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE-
DOCUMENT THAT IT'S PRODUCED AND
I JUST WANNA PUT ON THE RECORD
NOT JUST BE A RESUSCITATION OF
THE LAW BUT TO BE VERY DISTRICT
PARENTS- ALONG WITH THE RISKS
WHAT THE STATISTICS ARE AND
GIVING THEM TIPS AS TO HOW TO.
SECURE A FIREARM BECAUSE YOU'VE
SEEN PROP PAST TRAGEDIES THAT
THEY DON'T ALWAYS KNOW BUT THEY
DON'T REALIZE HOW INDUSTRIOUS
CHILDREN CAN BE WHEN THEY WANT
THEIR HANDS ON SOMETHING THAT
WAS IN THE HOUSE SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES
SUPPORT AND- THANK YOU ALL.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN. OF THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN AND
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH YOU HAVE
ACCEPTED A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FILE ITEM THREE AB TWO SEVENTY
SIX THE MOTION IS THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO BE TAKEN IN APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL. AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE DALY. DALY I'D
KALRA MCCARTY MCCARTY I'D SMITH
SMITH I LIVE WEBER WEBER I. SIX
SIXTY SIX WAS IT IS OUT THANK
YOU MISREAD AND THANK YOU TO
YOUR WITNESSES THANK YOU.
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU BOTH MADE A
TRIP UP HERE SO WE APPRECIATE
THAT YOUR PARTICIPATION TODAY
WITH THAT MISS MISS LOAN IS UP
COOPER GO BECAUSE YOU MADE.
PLANS TO BE FIRST AND YOU CAME
IN LATE SO ON YOUR WAY. UPSET
UNDERSTOOD MISTER COOPER IS
GOING TO BE EFFICIENT WITH THIS
TIME TO THIS WE APPRECIATE
THAT. I ACTUALLY SIGNED IN
FIRST BEFORE WAS LEVEL YEAH BUT
SHE HAD MADE PLANS FOR THE
COMMITTEE PREVIOUS TO THAT
MISTER COOPER THANK YOU I WOULD
NEVER LET YOU OFF THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- LEFT GOOD
AFTERNOON MISS CHAMBERS. BUT
LET ME LET ME FIGURE OUT WHAT
YOU'RE DOING HERE WOULD. FILE
ITEM ONE AB ONE FIFTY FILE ITEM
ONE. YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU
I AGREE THIS IS TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS MENTION IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY WOULD
BE ADOPTED IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. AND
BELIEVE YOU MEMBERS WILL MAKE
AB ONE FIFTY A BETTER BILL
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FIFTY REMOVE
BARRIERS FOR FOSTER YOUTH AND
OTHER HIGHLY MOBILE YOU THINK
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL ON
TIME IT WILL HELP ASSURE
THEY'RE SUPPORTED IN ACHIEVING
THEIR ACADEMIC GOALS. THIS BILL
IS INTENDED TO PROVE HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION RATES A POST
SECONDARY VOCATIONAL EDUCATION
OF SUCCESS FOR ALL HOW THE
MOBILE YOUTH REQUIRING THAT
SUMMER COURSE WERE COMPLETED
DIFFERENT SCHOOLS WITH
DIFFERENT COURSE TITLES IS
COMBINE TO OUR STUDENTS TO MEET
STATEMENT BLOOM GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS. FOR THIS BILL
SUPPORT HOW THE MOBILE YOUTH BY
HARDING SCHOOLS TO CALCULATE
ITS IMPARTIAL CREDITS INTO
ACCEPT PARTIAL CREDIT. FOR WORK
SATISFACTORILY COMPLETED.
LASTLY LET'S SAY THE COMMITTEE
STAFF ON THEIR WORK TO SUPPORT
IS COMPLEX AND TECHNICAL
ISSUES. WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT TESTIMONY IS
KRISTIN POWER THE ALLIANCE OF
CHILDREN'S CALIFORNIA'S. EXCUSE
ME THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS. HI GOOD AFTERNOON TERRY
MEMBERS I'M KRISTIN HOW THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
WE ARE PLEASED TO SPONSOR AB
ONE FIFTY TO THOUGHT SCHOOL
STABILITY FOR HIGHLY MOBILE
YOUTH INCLUDING YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE HOMELESS NEWCOMER AND
MIGRATORY YOUTH. AND THOSE
MILITARY FAMILIES BY PROVIDING
ADMINISTRATIVE AREAS FROM
IMPACTING THEIR PROGRESS TOWARD
GRADUATION. THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
DEAL WITH THE EFFECTS OF TRAUMA
AND LANGUAGE AND ECONOMIC
BARRIERS DALY WHILE NAVIGATING
SCHOOL CHANGES WHICH CAN
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THEIR
ACADEMIC PROGRESS AND SOCIAL
CONNECTIONS AND THEIR
MOTIVATION AND SELF WORTH.
ALLIANCE CLIENTS RACHEL STORY
WILL HELP EXPLAIN WHY AB ONE
FIFTY IS SO IMPORTANT. RACHEL
WAS REMOVED FROM HER PARENTS IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND CHANGED HOME
PLACEMENTS IN SCHOOLS SIX TIMES
IN HIGH SCHOOL AS YOUR SOCIAL
WORKER ATTEMPTED TO FIND THE
BEST PLACEMENT FOR HER AND HER
TWO YOUNGER BROTHERS. AT EACH
NEW SCHOOL RACHEL HAD TO LEARN
A NEW SET OF SCHOOL ROUTINE THE
POLICIES MAKE NEW FRIENDS MEET
WITH ADMINISTRATORS AND CATCH
UP ON CLASSES. SHE WAS
EXTREMELY FRUSTRATED WITH
SCHOOL SHE PREVIOUSLY ATTENDED
FAILED TO ISSUE CREDIT FOR THE
WORK SHE COMPLETED IMMENSELY
HADTO START HER CLASSES OVER
AND OVER AGAIN. THE RAILING HER
PROGRESS TOWARD BECOMING A
NURSE. FOR EXAMPLE WHEN SHE HAD
EARNED CREDITS IN ENGLISH NINE
AT A PRIOR SCHOOL ONE SCHOOL
TOLD HER SHE'D HAVE TO START
OVER BECAUSE THE NEW SCHOOL
OFFERED A COURSE CALLED ENGLISH
ONE. AND THEY WOULD NOT
COMBINED HER ENGLISH NINE
CREDITS WITH THE ENGLISH RUN
CREDITS TO GET HER ONE YEAR
COURSE NEEDED FOR GRADUATION.
EVENTUALLY RACIAL WAS FOR REFER
TO OUR ATTORNEYS THROUGH THEIR
ADVOCACY RACHEL WAS ABLE TO
COLLECT ALL OF HER CREDIT AND
HER ATTORNEYS WORKED WITH HER
TO DEVELOP GRADUATION PLAN
WITHOUT THAT ADVOCACY SHOULD
NOT RECEIVE YOUR CREDIT. WILL
NOT ABLE TO ACCUMULATE UNDER
THE STORE GRADUATION AND SHE
COULD. EASE SOMEONE UP 40% NOT
GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE DILIGENT
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF ON
THIS ISSUE. SO IMPORTANT TO
ACADEMIC SASSON ASK YOUR I'LL
GO TO SUPPORT OUR HIGHLY MOBILE
USE IN ACHIEVING THEIR ACADEMIC
GOALS. CREATE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL WE HAVE SEEN SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS AND WE'RE REVIEWING
THOSE AMENDMENTS BUT WE'VE ALSO
SO ALWAYS SUPPORTED MAKING SURE
THAT STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO GET
THROUGH IN GRADUATE WITHOUT-
BARRIERS THAT THEY FACE AS YOU
KNOW WE SERVE MANY HOMELESS
INCARCERATED. AND FOSTER YOUTH
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE LIKE
TO SEE THE BILL MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS TYLER MICKEY- I AM A
CURRENT GRAD STUDENT- THÅU
STATE NORTHRIDGE. I'M AN INTERN
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SPELL. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS BRENDAN TO IT ON
BEHALF OF THAT VOICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. I AND SEE NO FURTHER
IN SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU RING OF ACT HERE I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
BILL MISTER COOPER- YOU'RE
FIXING SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO
BE FIXED IN FACT I THINK YOU
SHOULD WE CAN EVEN TALK ABOUT
YOUR EXPANDING THIS OF IT TO
ALL GROUPS OF STUDENTS RIGHT
NOW THIS ADDRESSES ARE MORE
TRANSIT GROUPS OF STUDENTS
WHICH IS CERTAINLY NECESSARY.
BUT THERE'S NO REASON TO SAY
THIS BILL SHOULD APPLY TO ALL
STUDENT GROUPS QUITE FRANKLY SO
WE CAN HAVE THAT CONVERSATION.
AND AGAIN I EIGHT RIGHT WERE
DRESSING- AN ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
ONGOING FOR SOME TIME. STUDENTS
JUST SHOULD GET CREDIT-
ELECTIVE CREDIT THEY SHOULD GET
SUBJECT CREDIT FOR THE CLASSES
THEY'VE TAKEN EVEN IF IT'S
PARTIAL. SO I APPRECIATE THAT.
AND SOME OF OUR SCHOOLS AND IN
THE SCHOOL I TAUGHT IN MANY OR-
OUR STUDENTS ARE COMING IN AND
OUT. BY THE WAY THEY COME IN
OUT. THREE FOUR TIMES A YEAR TO
THE SAME SCHOOL AND OFF TO
ANOTHER BACK AND SO THIS IS A
REAL. REAL ISSUE IN FACT. I WAS
ONCE TOLD THE SCHOOL DISTRICT I
TAUGHT AND HAVE THE MOST
TRANSIT. NUMBER OF STUDENTS. IN
THE STATE. SINCE JUST COMING
OUT VIçT. FOSTER CARE
SITUATIONS FAMILY SITUATIONS
LIFE SITUATIONS SO I
APPRECIATE. THE BILL HERE
BEFORE US TODAY. WITH THAT TO
ANY OF THE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHICH TO SPEAK. IT'S
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED ARE YOU
MAY CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH AMENDMENTS.
TO BE PROCESSED. IN IN THAT
COMMITTEE. THE COLOR. FILE ITEM
ONE AB ONE FIFTY THE MOTION IS
THE PASTOR PREPARATIONS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN IN
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KILEY AYE.
DALY SALLY I KALRA. THIRTY THE
ICE SMITH SMITH I WEBER WEBER I
HAVE. THIS SIX WAS IT IS ALMOST
OVER. I WITH THAT I'M A SLOW
MOAN IS GOING TO COME FORWARD
AND LONG MISTER RAMOS THEY'RE
GOING TO PRESENT TOGETHER AND
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN READY. AND IF YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES THAT ARE GOING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT THEY MAY COME
FORWARD AS WELL RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED. AND
GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED AB SEVEN.
THIRTY EIGHT WHICH REQUIRES THE
I. Q. C. TO DEVELOP. AND THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION TO
ADOPT A NATIVE AMERICAN STUDIES
MODEL CURRICULUM BY MARCH
THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY.
THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY A. B.
FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO APPROPRIATE
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO FUND
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A MODEL
CURRICULUM IN NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDIES. AB FIFTY FIFTY TWO IS
THE NEXT STEP TO ENSURE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR
CURRICULUM THAT IS LONG
OVERDUE. RELEVANT AND ENGAGING
TO STUDENTS IN UNDERSTANDING
OUR HISTORY. AND THAT APPEARS.
IN THAT PREPARES THEM TO BE
GLOBAL CITIZENS FOR FAR TOO
LONG A COMPREHENSIVE AND
STATEWIDE MODEL CURRICULUM ON
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDIES HAS
BEEN MISSING. AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
TWO IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CORRECT THIS AND ALSO. BRING
THE WORK THE TRIBES HAVE DONE
FOR YEARS TO DOCUMENT THEIR
HISTORY TO A STATEWIDE LEVEL.
WHEN WE LEARN OUR COLLECTIVE
HISTORY REGARDLESS OF OUR
DIFFERENCES RELATE AND
UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER MUCH
BETTER. FOR THE BENEFIT OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENT IS
IMPORTANT. THAT WE IMPLEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES THAT PROVIDE A
SPACE OF BELONGING IN ACADEMIA.
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME JOINT
AUTHORS SOME REMEMBER JAMES
FROM AS WELL AS SAMPLING WITH
THE SHE MASH. TRIBE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MORE
FOR PURSUING- THIS BILL. THIS
BILL AIMS TO START TO CORRECT-
DIFFERENT PASS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS IT RELATES TO
CALIFORNIAN PEOPLE. THIS BILL
AB SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT WHEN IT
WAS PRESENT IT. DID NOT INCLUDE
FUNDING IMPLEMENTATION THAT'S
WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY. AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO AIMS TO
ENSURE THE FUNDING FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MOANS BILL WHICH WERE A
CULT AUTHOR ON. TO START TO
CORRECTLY PORTRAY- THE HISTORY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TOWARDS CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
PEOPLE. THESE ARE ISSUES OF WHY
WE'RE HERE THESE ARE ISSUES WHY
WE'RE ASKING FOR THIS BILL TO
MOVE FORWARD. AND TO REALLY.
ASK FOR THE CORRECT HISTORY TO
START TO BE TOLD. AND WHEN THAT
HAPPENS THAT BRINGS THE UNITY
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
ULTIMATELY GIVING IN CALIFORNIA
THE PEOPLE THE RIGHT WITH IN
THE AREA OF THE STATE TO BE
ABLE HAVE THOSE HISTORY BOOKS.
QUICKLY BETRAY THOSE THE
FUNDING MECHANISM STREAM IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE HERE TODAY
WITHIN THE BILL AND CO AUTHOR
ON THAT WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THE CURRENT BILL
REQUEST A MODEST EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO GO TO AYE
QC. TO START TO CORRECTLY.
PORTRAY THE PAST TOWARDS PEOPLE
HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
NORMAL FOR THE STATE AND
SOMETHING THAT WE STOOD
DEFINITELY STAND BEHIND. AND WE
URGE A YES VOTE ON THIS. THANK
YOU MISTER ALMOST YOUR WITNESS.
SAM COMING GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
AND LEGAL OFFICERS STANDING AS
SPEND OF CHUMASH INDIANS.
CHAIRMAN CON REGRETS HE CAN'T
BE HERE TODAY BUT THE ST YOU
KNOW SPEND OF CHUMASH INDIANS
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEAN FLANIGAN ON BEHALF OF
SCORN DRIVE IN SAN DIEGO IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. JIM
MEMBERS FRANK LEAVE ON BEHALF
OF THE SALMON WILL BETTER
MACHINE IS A STRONG SUPPORT.
PAMELA LOPEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
RING CONN BAND OF LUIS PENA
INDIANS IN THE CHILLY RIVER
TRIBE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SEE
NO OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SAYING
OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE- JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU MISTER RAMOS MISLI
MOAN OF FOR THE BILL. THE
SERRANO CERTAINLY BRING YOUR
SIGNIFICANT PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE- SO WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT- WITH THAT
MISTER KILEY BELIEVE YOU HAVE
COME. I'M NOT VERY HAPPY
SUPPORT THE BILL AND I WAS
REALLY ENCOURAGING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADVOCATES ON- THEIR VISION FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT THIS CURRICULUM
ONE THAT'S GOING TO BE. VERY
INCLUSIVE I THINK THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME WE'VE CONSIDERED A
MODEL CURRICULUM SINCE WE HAD
AN EXAMPLE OF THE MODEL
CURRICULUM LAST YEAR THAT WAS-
FAR FROM THAT. AND YOU KNOW
REALLY PRODUCED- PRETTY
DRAMATIC REBUKES FROM THIS
LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS THE
GOVERNOR AND THE EVEN THE
SUPERINTENDENT AND SELF SO I
JUST I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT- CD IS
FOLLOWING BEST PRACTICES WHEN
IT COMES TO CURRICULUM
DEVELOPMENT AND- FROM TO THE
EXTENT THAT THAT ADVOCATES OF
THIS BILL ARE GOING TO BE
PROVIDING INPUT I'M VERY
ENCOURAGED WHATEVER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NO COMMENTS MANY
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS STIR. AS
REGARDS YOU WISH TO COMMENT
YEAH I JUST WE HAVE COURSE
VOTEDON YOUR BILL A COUPLE
YEARS AGO ON THIS THIS BUILDS
UPON IT AND JUST WHAT I KNOW
THAT RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
AS WE KNOW THE STRONGEST WHEN
OUT THERE TOWARD IT. WE'RE
ABOUT TO LAUNCH THE CALIFORNIA
INDIAN HERE TO CENTER AND SO
THIS IS A- COUPLE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR PROJECT RIGHT
HERE AT THE CONFLUENCE OF TWO
RIVERS AND- RIGHT NOW THAT THE
HERITAGE OF THEY'VE AMERICANS
AND IN CALIFORNIA'S LITERALLY.
KIND OF A TOOL SHED OUTSIDE OF
pTHE DOUBLE MEANING FOR THE FOR
THAT AND SO. I THINK THIS IS
VERY TIGHTLY WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA LOOKING AT
OUR OUR HISTORY AND SPECIALLY
RELATE TO NATIVE AMERICANS AND
I THINK THIS WILL THIS WILL
BLEND WELL WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE. RIGHT HERE IN WEST
SACRAMENTO. THANK YOU. I GOT
RIVER YES I WANT TO. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND OBVIOUSLY THIS WILL
MEAN A LOT- JUST IN TERMS OF
CONTEXT UP. IT MAY PRODUCE
CONTROVERSY- WHICH IS ALWAYS
GOOD- BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVEN'T
HAD KNOWLEDGE OF HISTORY
SOMETIMES HISTORY ITSELF.
BECOMES OFFENSIVE TO PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE DOING. AND I THINK THAT
WAS THE CASE WITH LAST YEAR
WITH THE ETHNIC STUDIES
CURRICULUM. SO IT WASN'T REALLY
THAT THEY WENT AWRY IT'S A
PULSE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE DEALING WITH DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO EXPECT. AND THAT MAY
HAPPEN WITH THIS WITHOUT HAVING
BEEN IN ETHNIC STUDIES THE LAST
FIFTY SOME ODD YEARS. AS A
PROFESSOR OFTENTIMES NEW
INFORMATIONSHOCKS PEOPLE. IS
NOT ALWAYS A HAPPY EXPERIENCE
BUT IT'S A VERY NECESSARY
EXPERIENCE AND I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'VE DONE- AND- WE LOOK
FOR TO HAVE CALIFORNIA
EVENTUALLY HAVING A CURRICULUM.
THAT REALLY REPRESENTS ALL OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. THANK YOU SEE
NO FOR THE COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE YOU MAY CLOSE BOTH OF
YOU. THIS WATER THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU UP. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MONIQUE LMON ONE FOR BRINGING
THIS ISSUE FORWARD. I THANK
OTHER MEMBERS AND THAT WE ARE
JUST AYE VOTE TO START TO
CORRECT THE HISTORY. IT WAS
PERPETRATED AGAINST CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE THANK YOU. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- GREAT- WITH THAT THE MOTION
<c.red>S TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.</c>
THE SECRETARY MAY CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. FILE ITEM FOR AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO. THE MOTION
IS THE PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL. TRACK O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY. KILEY AYE DELI. DELI I
KALRA MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
SMITH. SMITH I WEBER WEBER I'D-
SIX VOTES THE BILL IS UP. WHICH
IS. CASEY SIXTEEN OUR DATA FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWO SIXTEEN
BY DR WEBBER SHE WILL PERCENT
NOW. SEC. YEAH. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- TODAY I HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF PRESENTING AB TWO
SIXTEEN WITH THE STATUS OF%
PEOPLE AND SAFETY OF STAFF
SAFETY PILOT PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
SCHOOL STAFFING TRAINING ON
ALTERNATIVES TO PHYSICAL
RESTRAINT AND SECLUSION OF
STUDENTS AND DE ESCALATION
STRATEGIES- WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL
THE WORK WITH IT WITH THIS BILL
AND- WE OBVIOUSLY WILL OUR PRES
WITH THOUGH THE WAY IT HAS COME
OUT AND SO WE APPRECIATE THE
UP- RECOMMENDATIONS- TOO OFTEN
STUDENTS WITH MOST SIGNIFICANT
DISABILITIES SUCH AS AUTISM ANY
EMOTIONAL DISTURBANCE OUR PLACE
TO DANGEROUS IN AN APPROPRIATE
RESTRAINTS AND CAN AND
SECLUSION THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. CURRENTLY TWELVE
STATES VANCE INCLUSION OF ALL
STUDENTS ONE EIGHTEEN DO SO
WOULD STUDENTS WITH DISABILITY
ALONE NINETEEN STATES PROTECT
ALL STUDENTS LIMITING STRANGE
INSTANCE THREAT OF PHYSICAL
DANGER CALIFORNIA'S FALLING
BEHIND FEDERAL GUIDELINES
PRACTICES ADOPTED BY STATE DO
SEE USE OF THESE DANGERS
PRACTICES AND INSTEAD IMPLEMENT
POSITIVE BEHAVIOR TECHNIQUES AS
A PART OF A STATEWIDE EFFORT TO
RESTRICT THE USE OF THREE
STRENGTHENS THE COLLUSION ALONG
WITH THE GOVERNOR SOME
COMMITMENT TO PROVIDING SAFER
INCLUSIVE CLASSROOMS CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL STAFF NEEDS TO BE FULLY
TRAINED. ON DE ESCALATION
TECHNIQUES TV'S. AB TWELVE
FIFTEEN AS A FOLLOW UP BILL. AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN WHICH
PROHIBITED RESTRAINTS AND
SECLUSION IN SCHOOLS UNLESS THE
STUDENTS BEHAVIOR PRINT
PRESENTS AN IMMEDIATE DANGER OF
SERIOUS HARM TO THE STUDENTS
ARE OTHERS. PROVIDING TRAINING
FOR THESE SITUATIONS WILL HELP
PREVENT SITUATIONS AS A ONE IN
EL DORADO COUNTY AND COUNTLESS
OTHERS ACROSS THE STATE. AB
TWENTY SIXTEEN ESTABLISHES THE
PEOPLE AND STAFF SAFETY PILOT
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY THE
EXISTING SCALE UP THEM TSS
STATEWIDE PROJECT. IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THIS PROGRAM WILL
AWARD GRANTS TO LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES FOR THE
PURPOSE OF TRAINING SCHOOL
STAFF. ON ALTERNATIVES TO
SECRETION AND RESTRAINT AND
SAFER DE ESCALATION TECHNIQUES
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
IS SUPPORTED BY THE ALLIANCE
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR.
EDUCATE ADVOCATE AND OTHERS
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND TO
OFFER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ON A
BEACH TO SIXTEEN IS GREGORY
KRAMER FROM DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. AND MILLAR ERIC'S
ERICSSON'S TAMINO OF PORT VIEW
PREPARATORY SCHOOL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA. I DONT LIKE
TO THINK THE AUTHOR HER STAFF
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US ON DEVELOPING THE
PROPOSAL THAT YOU HAVE TODAY-
THIS PILOT PROGRAM WILL AWARD
GRANTS ELEAZAR FOR THE PURPOSE
OF TRAINING SCHOOL STAFF ON
ALTERNATIVES TO SECLUSION AND
RESTRAINT. BUILDING OFF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBBER'S
PREVIOUS EFFORTS AND- LIKE
DOCTOR WEBER DOT- DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA SPOT FOR
YEARS TO CURB THE USE OF
SECLUSION AND RESTRAINT TACTICS
AND TECHNIQUES. AND WE BELIEVE
THAT TRAINING ON. TECH IS A
STEP TO PROTECT THE HEALTH OF
PEOPLE SOME STAFF AND PROVIDE
FOR A BETTER PREPARED WORKFORCE
AND AS REFLECTED IN THE
ANALYSIS PEOPLE'S AND WITH
DISABILITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY SUBJECTED TO
RESTRAINTS AND SECLUSION
ACCORDING TO THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
REPORTER RELEASE IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES REPRESENTED ONLY
12% OF THE NATIONAL STUDENT
POPULATION BUT ACCOUNTED 458%
OF THOSE PLACE IN SECLUSION AND
75% OF THOSE SUBJECTED. TO
PHYSICAL RESTRAINT. THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATIONAL ON
THAT PHYSICAL RESTRAINTS AND
SECLUSION WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY USE FOR
BLACK PEOPLE'S ACROSS THE
COUNTRY REGARDLESS OF THEIR
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION SCHOOL OR
ECONOMIC STATUS. CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT OFFER
STANDARDIZE TRAININGS TO
PREVENT THE RESTRAINT AND
SECLUSION OF STUDENTS BY
EMPHASIZING DE ESCALATION
TECHNIQUES AND SO ACCORDINGLY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND HAVE
DEVELOPED PRACTICES TO PREVENT
RESTRAIN SECLUSION AND OR HAVE
BEEN LEGALLY COMPELLED TO WHAT
THE ESTABLISHMENT. COMES
INITIATIVE IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
THE STATE TOOK A FOLKS APPROACH
TO INTEGRATE POSITIVE
BEHAVIORAL- SUPPORTS IN
CALIFORNIA CLASSROOMS AND WERE
ALSO HEARTENED BY THE EFFORTS.
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE ON A DOCTOR
WEBBER'S PREVIOUS LEGISLATION.
MEANWHILE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CONTINUES TO ADVANCE
REFORMS TO USE OF RESTRAINTS
AND SECLUSION SEND THE STATE
MUST BE PREPARED TO FOLLOW
SUIT. LAST YEAR SECRETARY OF
EDUCATION BETSY TO BOSS
ANNOUNCED AN INITIATIVE TO
EXAMINE THE INAPPROPRIATE USE
OF RESTRAINT AND SECLUSION IN
OUR NATION'S SCHOOLS. AND
ADDITIONALLY SEVERAL STATES
HAVE TAKEN ACTION TO REFORM-
THEIR OWN INTERNAL RESTRAIN
SECLUSION POLICIES SO. THE LACK
OF DE ESCALATION TRAINING. HAS
RESULTED IN PREVENTABLE STUDENT
DEATHS INJURIES AND TRAUMA
ALONG WITH PHYSICAL HARM AND
CRIMINAL CHARGES FOR SCHOOL
STAFF AND CLASS ACTION LAWSUITS
AGAINST NUMBERS COUNTIES OF
EDUCATION. CALIFORNIA COULD
AVOID THESE CITIES AND
LIABILITIES BY- OFFERING PROPER
TRAINING AND DE ESCALATION
TECHNIQUES AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WERE PROP SPONSORED
BILL AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS I AM DOCTOR
MILLER ERICKSON TO ME NOW AND I
AM A BOARD CERTIFIED BEHAVIOR
ANALYSTS LICENSE PSYCHOLOGIST
AND DOCTOR OF DEVELOPMENTAL
PSYCHOLOGY. I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING STUDENTS
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH TWENTY TWO
YEARS OF AGE WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AS ONE OF THE FOUNDERS AND
PRINCIPLES OF PORT BE
PREPARATORY A NON PUBLIC SCHOOL
WITH CAMPUSES IN ORANGE AND
SAN. YOU KNOW COUNTIES. WE HAVE
CONSULTED WITH AN AUDIT YES
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY
EXAMINING THEIR BEHAVIOR
INTERVENTION PRACTICES. DURING
THESE OBSERVATIONS THE
CONSISTENT THEME IS LACK OF
RESOURCES AND TRAINING FOR
THOSE SERVING STUDENTS WITH
BEHAVIORAL AND EMOTIONAL
CHALLENGES. IT IS FOR THIS
REASON WE ARE ASKING THAT YOU
SUPPORT AND PASS EIGHTY TWO
SIXTEEN. AB TWO SIXTEEN
SPECIFICALLY TARGETS THIS GAP
IN TRAINING. BY PROVIDING LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPLY FOR GRANT
FUNDING TO SUPPORT TRAINING
EFFORTS THE POST TRAINING
RESULT WILL BE EMPOWERED
EDUCATORS WHO ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE PRO ACTIVE
INTERVENTION. USING THE LIKE OF
STUDENT INJURY OR TRAUMA.
DURING THE LAST SIX MONTHS
WE'VE IN OVER A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EDUCATORS AND SUPPORT
PERSONNEL AND FOUND THAT WAS A
LOT JUST. SEE IN WHAT OUR
EDUCATORS THINK THING AND WHAT
THEY NEED TO KNOW TO BEST SERVE
THE STUDENTS. THROUGH PRE AND
POST TRAINING SURVEYS AND
COLLECTION ANECDOTAL DATA WE
HAVE FOUND THAT WHILE EDUCATORS
WANT TO LEARN AND HAVE A LARGE-
TO HELP THERE'S- WITH CHECK.
HERE THEY LACK THE TRAINING
RESOURCE TO DO SO FOR EXAMPLE
SALTS. OF THEM FELT THAT THEY
POSSESS THE KNOWLEDGE TO MANAGE
THESE BEHAVIORS IN A SCHOOL
SETTING. FOLLOWING TRAINING
EDUCATOR SHARED THAT THEY WERE
ABLE TO DEVELOP MORE EFFECTIVE
BEHAVIOR INTERVENTION PLANS AND
REDUCE CHALLENGING BEHAVIORS
QUICKLY WITHIN THEIR CLASSROOM.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
WE CAN GIVE EDUCATORS THE
TRAINING THAT THEY NEED TO
SERVE STUDENTS WITH CHALLENGING
BEHAVIOR SO THAT THEY DO NOT
FIND THEMSELVES WITHOUT THE
NECESSARY TOOLS. TO EDUCATE AND
KEEP THEIR STUDENTS SAFE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS KAELIN DEAN
WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND
MEN OF COLOR AT POLICY LINK
STRONG SUPPORT. HELLO I'M WENDY
KEATING. AND I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF BOTH EDUCATE ADVOCATE
AND EMPOWER FAMILY CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SIXTEEN. THANK YOU. SANDRA
BREAUX ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION WE HAVEN'T TAKEN AN
OFFICIAL POSITION YET BUT ARE
LIKELY TO SUPPORT THANKS. THANK
YOU- SEE NO FURTHER SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION. SING OPPOSITION
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- THANK YOU DOCTOR
OVER FOR THE BILL I THINK ANY
TIME WE CAN TRAIN PEOPLE ON A
SCHOOL SITE IS HOW BEST TO DEAL
WITH CHILDREN. OUR IS A GOOD
THING. AND THAT'S I THINK
YOU'RE OVER ARCHING GOAL HERE I
WITH THAT ANY. I MISS SMITH.
I'D LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE FORWARD I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE LAST FALL OF VISITING
A NON PUBLIC SCHOOL PRIVATE
PLACEMENT SETTING FOR SOME OF
MY REGION'S MOST CHALLENGED
EMOTIONALLY DISTURBED CHILDREN
AND WHAT WAS AN IMPRESSIVE TO
ME IS THE EXTENT TO WHICH THE
STAFF WAS REALLY EMBRACING NOT
ONLY THE LATEST IN RESEARCH
DEVELOP TECHNIQUES BUT ACTUALLY
EMPLOYED THEIR OWN RESEARCHERS
IN THE FIELD OF BOTH
KINESIOLOGY AND ENGINEERING
FIRMS OF DEVELOPING SAFE
PHYSICAL RE DIRECTION- AND THEN
HAD COMPLETELY REVAMPED.
CONCEPT OF COLLUSION IT REALLY
CAME MORE ABOUT TEACHING AN
EMPOWERING THESE CHILDREN WITH
THE TECHNIQUES TO LEARN TO DE
ESCALATE THEMSELVES AND I THINK
THEY'RE REALLY ULTIMATELY AS
EDUCATORS THAT'S WHAT ALL IS
FOR ALL OF US SO I THINK VERY
MUCH IS VERY THE MEASUREMENT
PLAN TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS FOR MANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS YOU MAKE CLOTHES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BUILT FOR AB TWENTY. TWO S<c.cyan></c>
SIXTY TWO DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THIS. MOVED AND SECONDED. IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. YOU
MAKE SECTOR-LIMóN CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE FILE ITEM TO AB TWO
SIXTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL ACT O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE DELI DELI I
KALRA MCCARTY. RT ICE SMITH
SMITH I WEBER WEBER I. THE
RULES OUT WAS SIX VOTES THANK
YOU. WITH THAT. CAN I DURING
OKAY OUT AND I JUST A I WON
AGAIN A KNOWLEDGE MAKING DAHLE
THESE PRESENCE HERE TODAY GOOD
JOB IS PROBABLY YOUR QUICKEST
MEETING OF THE YEAR ON THE
EDUCATION FRONT- BUT WELCOME TO
IT. WITH THAT THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED